[Musica]
salve a tutti a tutti
allora me capita ma penso che capiti
anche voi questo che qua ci sono io il
microfono a me capita spesso di trovarmi
nella vita mi è capitato e so che mi
capiterà ancora di trovarmi in
situazioni dove non sto proprio bene non
sto bene perché magari io mi aspettavo
cose diverse oppure non perché ci sono
le cose che mi aspettavo però le persone
che sono lì non sono esattamente in
sintonia con me con quello che succede
oppure sono situazioni che succedono
succede qualcosa di improvviso per cui
cambia tutto quello che che mi ero
aspettato succedesse o proprio si creano
dei guai dei problemi allora io ho
pensato non
cosa ci insegnano fin da piccole cose si
solito si dice no e dai
accontentati
accontenta ed ai si vabbè ed è andata
così accontentati oppure no
ribellati
sebbene la tribù re ma via quindi fuggo
fuggire a ribellarsi o accontentarsi che
la cosa più semplice dice vabbè dai
quando dura questa cosa qui dura un'ora
poi è finita sono qui va a 15 minuti dai
viste poi dov'è finita accontentate
in realtà poi questa cosa qui non mi ha
mai riso nata bene non mi ha mai
soprattutto permesso poi di vivere
questi qui e ora in maniera che poi dopo
ripensandoci o nel nel tempo le cose che
potevo imparare risultava passavano e
non mi rimaneva niente allora in negli
anni ho sviluppato
una forma di sapere quindi proprio una
delle conoscenze estremamente pratica e
quindi l'olio sviluppate io sono mie
io ve ne racconto però non è un sapere
teorico di quelli che si trasmettono
culturalmente eccetera e una cosa che vi
racconto che che condividiamo tutti però
è questo sapere io l'ho potuto
sviluppare soprattutto negli ultimi 15
anni
in cui sono stato appunto ruben camillas
i camillas sono esistiti dal 2004 al
ruben camillas ero io poi c'è la zagor
camillas poi negli anni sono arrivati
altri fratelli michael camillas theodore
camillas eravamo fratelli senza genitori
è una cosa che ci dicevamo tra di noi e
noi eravamo un gruppo musicale che
soprattutto suonava dal vivo trovava
nella dimensione dal vivo il luogo in
cui si sentiva più di essere e di fare
musica e di esserci quindi noi facciamo
abbiamo fatto centinaia di concerti in
ogni situazione locali matrimoni
inaugurazioni abbiamo fatto le chiusure
dei locali abbiamo fatto nelle chiese e
centri sociali nelle strade senza
amplificazione con l'amplificazione
tutti questi concerti tutti questi
eventi di spostamenti le mille
situazioni in cui mi sono trovato mi
hanno insegnato che hanno appunto
permesso di sviluppare questo sapere
e questa sera sono qui a raccontarvi in
un po è anche una forma di gratitudine
perché dal 2020 il da aprile 2020 i
camillas non ci sono più
zagor camillas è scomparso il 14 aprile
e da quel momento qui il momento lì i
camillas non ci sono più e essere qui a
parlare di queste cose anche una forma
per me di gratitudine nei suoi confronti
che il reciprocamente siamo stati
maestro e allievo e abbiamo affrontato
tante cose con cosa predispongo
lo schermo
alla prima situazione prima cosa è
mettere in gioco alla convenienza
convenienza come noli quando cioè lì no
non conviene andiamo fino no non
conviene fare questa cosa qui no non
conviene noi ci siamo trovati una volta
a milano in un evento di quelle
liberamente milano
superassessore di milano tutti i super
super scrittore e superato retro queste
situazioni lì dove c'erano capitati per
caso per vie traverse si chiamano anche
noi li ha fine e noi abbiamo fatto
quello che volevamo fare
abbiamo un po colpito il pubblico e s'è
presentato un signore che è un notissimo
giornalista teatrale di radio popolare
sandro d'avanzo è arrivato sandro
d'avanzo presentiamo sandro d'avanzo
giornalista così in quel momento lì la
cosa giusta da fare era se serve si
sapeva fare anche il leader sia così
invece lì in quel momento lì perché
quella situazione diventasse memorabile
non diventasse che torni a casa così si
è presentato sand rilevanza hassan
davanzante romanzo detto sandro d'avanzo
sandro avanzo e molte aree molte o nel
nome
e lui e lui si è fermato ci ha pensato e
vero non me l'ha detto però su una
testata
ed era però la cosa giusta da fare è
certo il tipo che era lì con noi ha
detto ma non avete neanche detto che voi
domani suonate e la convenienza andava
messo in gioco perché quella situazione
lì venisse sentita forte che venisse
ricordata l'altra cosa è la il rischio
il rischio perché nelle situazioni in
cui ci si trova bisogna sempre rischiare
in senso di in qualche modo arrivare
fino a mettersi in una situazione un po
di disequilibrio e di insicurezza noi
centro la prima volta ci avevo chiamato
per fare un colloquio non sembrate fare
un colloquio milano un colloquio per una
trasmissione televisiva anno erano stati
televisione dell'innovazione 13 donne
facile in televisione con logo e noi
arriviamo invece in questo cortile dove
c'erano tanti attori che provavano
da attori a quello quello come la quel
famoso e mi ha capito che eravamo a una
a una selezione in realtà saranno famosi
commissione e noi invece erano andati lì
per un colloquio quindi il caffè allora
in quella situazione lì la cosa no
facciamo diciamo che noi non avevamo
capito
andiamo a casa oppure diciamo no andiamo
su ogni cosa facciamo noi siamo
musicisti facciamo una canzone e poi
cosa cosa diciamo che facciamo noi
diciamo che siamo dei mimi
per cui noi tutti siamo stati di tre
minuti dicendo che eravamo dei mimi
senza fare i minimi perché è complicato
fare minimi in azione mentre invece dire
che sei un mimo e facilissimo perché
sono un mimo a ripeterlo continuamente è
altrettanto facile però in quella
situazione lì è il come dire mettersi in
una situazione dove è un attimo che
diventi che ti tirano le cose oppure che
ti mandano via gentilmente però comunque
è invece lì bisognava rischiare e questo
modo qui poi dopo è la la situazione è
evoluta nel modo anche ottimale tutto
positivamente e l'altra cosa
e il paradosso
arriva arrivare vive le situazioni
cercando di forzarle dal punto di vista
del loro contenuto paradossale cioè
proprio nel rovesciarle non siamo stati
chiamati come camillas al festival della
filosofia di modena quindi nel programma
tutti i filosofi in fondo ci eravamo noi
il tema del del festival era la fine
l'impresa festivalfilosofia però si sta
anche noi potremmo discutere
alla fine ci hanno affidato questo tema
allora noi abbiamo scritto un testo
velocemente perché dove non si capiva se
parlavamo della fine dell'amore o della
fine di una situazione però non ci
interessava noi volevamo andare lì a
suonare e mentre quando abbiamo iniziato
mentre noi abbiamo detto ci siamo
proprio guardatevi benedetto non finiamo
più
e abbiamo suonato per quattro ore
c'è stata è stata una cosa
è come dire
perché di dirlo lo dico oppure ce lo
potevamo dire prima in realtà è stato
deciso nel momento in cui erano lì
perché abbiamo capito che eravamo in una
situazione
reale no in cui eravamo con il pubblico
alle persone che erano lì si era creata
che c'erano delle condizioni
il concerto ha iniziato presto quindi
c'era tanto tempo erano successe cose
insomma positiva per cui li abbiamo
sfidato la fine non smettiamo vivo
ovviamente essendo un pezzo alla
filosofia non erano attrezzati a
bloccarci
rispetto
e noi siamo siamo stati dentro l'altra
cosa è giocare con
la verosimiglianza la probabilità e le
improbabilità delle cose
il cammino se avevano un contenuto su di
loro che era la città di provenienza qua
quando noi siamo nati abbiamo scritto il
camillas sono nate pordenone in realtà
san di pesaro
proprio noi siamo mai stati a pordenone
siamo stati una da grandi e questa cosa
qua che era nata per gioco poi dopo
siamo accorti che
utilizzata come contenuto comunicativo
come elemento che tornava costantemente
creava una sorta di
[Musica]
asimmetria nel momento in cui noi ci
trovavamo nei luoghi perché c'erano
persone che avevano capito che noi
eravamo dipesero altre persone che noi
romani di peso come eravamo nati a
pordenone altri che noi eravamo di
pordenone
benché parlassimo il pesarese quindi
c'erano tanti tanti elementi di da un
dato
appoggiato lì con molta naturalezza su
myspace che all'epoca sarà myspace ha
appoggiato lì così questa cosa è stata
per noi un elemento che ci ha permesso
in tante situazioni
come dire di spostare un po all'ovvietà
e la consequenzialità
normale delle cose con questo dato
quando siamo stati in totale il corriere
di pordenone ha fatto mezza pagina con
scritto falsi pordenonesi
e noi roma fierissimi perché siamo
riusciti a creare una cosa di un
stravolgimento il cosa caratterizza un
po queste queste storiche che vi ho
raccontato ci hanno un elemento quando
quando gli ho messo un po in fila la
cosa che le caratterizza tutte e che
sono come dire
abbiamo messo in gioco delle la
convenienza il paradosso è accesa abbia
messo il gioco in situazioni in cui non
eravamo soli cioè non sono cose che
accadono nella testa ma accadono una
collettività in un ambiente comunitario
in un gruppo di persone in una nel nel
momento in cui c'è uno scambio è questo
qui è l'elemento fondamentale che sento
anche che è rimasto rispetto alla nostra
storia e rispetto anche all
apprendimento cioè che in realtà
qualsiasi situazione poi di difficoltà
di incomprensione o anche di
insofferenza poi in realtà va sempre
giocata nella collettività perché poi
stando nella tua testa a parte che
pochissimo divertente perché sei già
tutto quello che c'è
mentre che se con gli altri poi le cose
possono improvvisamente diventare
diverse e migliori rispetto a come tu te
le aspetti e l'altra cosa fondamentale
poi che mi è venuta fuori molte volte
questa parola è il discorso del gioco
del giocare noi spesso come camilla
quando ci chiedevano no voi cosa fate
no perché ci aveva fatto i cabaret così
noi giochiamo noi giochiamo per davvero
ed ed era un modo per per dire che il
gioco viene un po per abitudine no
associato
sport l'infanzia
l'azzardo non c'è sempre un po
caratterizzato ma in realtà il gioco è
un modo di stare al mondo
è un modo per stare al mondo che fa sì
che in ogni situazione in qualche modo
di ogni situazione tira fuori un po
quegli elementi anche la più seria tira
fuori quegli elementi che in qualche
modo la possono rendere più libera la
possono rendere anche meno legata
all'obiettivo quindi anche più
improduttiva in qualche modo però è una
non produttività che in realtà produce
tanti altri effetti e poi sono e poi
soprattutto il gioco è facilmente
condivisibile e
coinvolge il gioco 15 ci riporta a
quella situazione che vi dicevo prima
della collettività e della comunità
quindi queste qui sono le cose che ho
qui per voi voi non le vedete ma io le
vedo perché qua c'è il paradosso c'è la
convenienza e c'è il rischio adesso ci
sono 73 fortunati che potranno avere a
disposizione queste cose qua se circola
è laggiù
lui lì
è questo qui lo tiro come un bouquet che
lo prenda il rischio
chi lo prende stasera starà benissimo
grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]